やんだ
僕の名前は飛び出すつを今日皆さんに良い商品を紹介しようと思うんだ
もうつつ誤飲に良いのを紹介しようと思うんだお菓子した彼女はいいかな
smoke and 1人しか嫌い4肘けどまぁやっぱり違ったエロさにょんちゃんだ
これぐらいの彼女より僕は持っておき可能とか欲しいんだよ
そういうことなんざ総合彼はなんだよ僕は実は心臓があるんだぞ
心臓僕や心臓が僕だ神とか一つしかないんだ
だから今日もよしお菓子扇者に紹介しようと思います
これはハイチュウいいだろみんな好きだろハイチュウがんっ
ん
みんなどうだい食べたいだろ誰だやろ
じゃあメダロット2べたいとだめだろと言います縫いますで食べたじゃろちゃーみたい
けどたみたいだかってありたいだろ
愛犬愛人の茶妻とけんかしてちょっとテンションが低いですはじめ社長です
こんなハイチュウ度も見たこと悩みやをままで見たことないか
今日すごい楽しみなんだ
さあで扱わないか八かないっですん
演奏せず
母も水を何が入ってるんだこのハイチュウ
おっとアーマー四谷大塚10分入って撃っ
僕の指の数と同じだねはいおっトンといっしょ怒ったリーグもの
ん
なぜ色はちょっと黒っぽい
匂いはもう売っても良くないねそうで集って早速食べてみよう
わー
浦井糸の味するでークイーンの
思っても美味しい
7心から映画をになれる恥なん
ものだかん市場の味が
ん
しっかりして病に日本でゾンビとかなと言ったらまさに
相当経験がゼロなの再現されてとっても美味しいん
ああああああああ
ni